it has trialed the technology now it's
to begin using it for real
Scotland Yard's says facial recognition
cameras will be vital in spotting
criminal suspects and missing and
vulnerable people
police say the system won't retain
images of anybody not on a watch list
every image that is looked at by the
technology if there is no match its
instantaneously deleted so it's a
momentary momentary comparison if it's
not a matches instantaneously deleted
the only images that are retained are
those where there's been an alert and
they are retained for a maximum of 31
days but privacy campaigners say the
move is a stain on the new government's
human rights record never before have
members of the public been treated like
walking ID cards subjected to an ongoing
police lineup that our identities have
to be biometrically checked to make sure
we're not criminals that's a complete
inversion of the of the traditional
presumption of innocence that is so at
the heart of British civil liberties and
that's why I think this is none less
than an assault on our rice
police say the technology works like
this the faces of anyone not on a watch
list appear pixelated this is what
happens when a suspect above is caught
in the crowd below the potential match
alerts officers on the ground and they
decide whether to approach the suspect
at least three police forces have been
piloting the technology here the South
Wales force used it to monitor football
fans when one passerby challenged its
use for High Court back to the police
there are conflicting statistics about
the accuracy of facial recognition
technology the home office said it fully
supported police in its use not in Brunt
Sky News